3 mai 2016 fort mcmurray brûle
pris au piège les gens fuient menacée
la puissance des flammes a été sans
équivoque le quartier beacon violent et
dévasté son sol contaminé tous tes
cendres maintenant
non
sur ces images monochromes les teintes
de gris se mélangent
une scène qui rappelle les grandes
guerres immobile le vent soulève la
poussière des ruines
les souvenirs s'effacent les décombres
eux restent figées
où
la nature a repris ses droits quelques
jours à peine après le passage de l'un
110 voilà deux jeunes pousses bien par s
la verdure couvre maintenant le sol les
traces laissées par le feu ces stands la
forêt le feu s'affrontent depuis
toujours
au fil des combats la forêt s'est adapté
il en ressortira plus forte plus riche
encore une fois
la leçon est claire forme et mairie doit
être mieux protégés on doit la tenir à
bonne distance des feux de forêt alors
au pourtour de la ville ont fait de la
coupe à blanc le coupe feu mesure 30
mètres de largeur pour être efficace la
lisière sera régulièrement nettoyés les
arbres ne doivent plus servir de
carburant ne doivent plus alimenter le
feu
et
une ville s'est implanté au milieu de la
forêt boréale le charme que confèrent
les arbres un certain quartier offre à
ses habitants une incroyable quiétude
mais cette cohabitation représente un
danger réel
l' équilibre entre les deux demeurent
précaires
on sait maintenant que la sécurité doit
primer